Decidí irme también porque allá hay otro
estilo de vida pues allá podría yo a mi
familia Podría tener muchas cosas más
que aquí no lo voy a tener que salir el
día 12 de septiembre Duré casi un mes y
medio para poder llegar a México
lo más difícil fue hacerlo
porque duramos siete días y medio
caminando
si duramos dos días y medio caminando
sin comer porque Se nos acabó la comida
y se veía muchísima gente cruzando por
esa selva también mucha gente que se
quedó ahí durmiendo en esa frontera
también en calpa con niños la mayoría
todo eran venezolanos hay mucha gente
también que se cae en países Trabajando
para poder reunir el pasado y para poder
seguir salir de Panamá a Costa Rica
llegué en la tarde noche salimos un
autobús así no me quedaba mucho pero en
México Duré casi un mes también
ya nosotros nos hemos entregado el día a
día de migración y estábamos presos
nosotros no sabíamos nada duramos cuatro
días presos y cuando nos sueltan No
bajan por el puente de México y nos
dicen que no han ahí no hagan una visa
un papel para poder entrar de forma
legal Cuando llegamos abajo tenemos un
papel de deportación también de México
Tenemos que salir en 15 días y fue
cuando nos enteramos que habían puesto
el título 42
y nada y todo el mundo empezó a llorar
todo el mundo se quedó como que está
pasando
yo gasté en todo el trayecto para llegar
a Estados Unidos como 1800 dólares
y mucha plata prestada también
muchos familiares que me ayudaron ya con
todo ese viaje yo quedé endeudado y por
eso decidí regresarme trabajar y pagando
poco a poco
no aquí la situación en Venezuela es
difícil
por la economía que por lo menos ahorita
un sueldo aquí no te alcanza o sea te
alcanza como para comprar comida Cuando
regresé llegué a mi mismo trabajo que
era el taller donde yo trabajo
trabajamos a domicilio también
la persona que no se fueron así pues es
muy rudo y más iban con niños yo no
volvería a emigrar porque se pasa mucho
trabajo pues la única manera que yo miré
que yo pueda sacar mi pasaporte todo
legal y pueda viajar un avión directo
sin tanto problema